13 lawyers representing
37 petitioners are asking supreme court
justices
to scrap an anti-terror law the
legislation's
championed by president rodrigo duterte
and backed
by the military but the scale of this
legal challenge to the government
is unprecedented any one of us can
actually be branded as a terrorist
based on the definition of terrorism in
the law for example as i speak now
they can interpret this as terrorism
which is also our message to the
filipino people
we should get involved we should be
informed about this we should study
what this law is all about because this
is not just about us
lawyers we are fighting for our civil
liberties and for our future
the anti-terror law broadens the
definition of terrorism
and allows the military to expand
surveillance and detain
suspects for weeks without charge
the government says it needs the law to
fight insurgent groups
in many parts of the country and the
national security adviser says
it is designed to protect civil
liberties
it's a democratic process
we should allow this to happen terrorism
is real
critics say the government has
weaponized the law to systematically
stifle dissent
democracy they say is under siege this
is why they turn to the supreme court
they say
as the filipino people's last line of
defense against tyranny
jamella alindogan al jazeera manila